I'm so glad that we've had the opportunity to team up with Goldman Sachs.
...on this important program for US and UK small businesses.
Having started a small business from scratch,...
...I know how tough it can be.
The days are long and the work never ends.
Each day brings new challenges.
But, there's never been a challenge quite like the one we are facing today.
At Bloomberg, we've been a strong supporter of the 10,000 small businesses program for years.
And we're ready to help now as you navigate the coronavirus crisis...
...and work to adapt and survive.
And eventually, with a little luck, start growing again.
So, I want to thank Goldman Sachs for their partnership...
...and all of you for joining us today.
You are the backbone of our economies and communities.
And the work that you've been doing means so much...
...not only to you and your employees, but to all of us.
We're all in this together.
Thank you, take care and all the best.